Hollywood has a reputation for housing secrets,
but sometimes with major casting announcements,
the audience reaction winds up being something
like, "yawn, we already knew that" followed
by maybe a polite golf clap.
"Golf clap?"
"Golf clap."
(golf clap)
This is because, thanks to leaks and common
sense, the public already scooped the big
news long before the studio made it official.
Here are a few of the worst-kept casting secrets
in Hollywood.
Brie Larson as Captain Marvel
There were a bunch of names in play as to
who'd become Captain Marvel in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe, but once Brie Larson scored
her Best Actress Oscar for Room, she seemed
like the obvious choice.
"Because I love the way that she, like, commands
herself and owns her, like, womanness."
She has the versatility, the critical cachet,
and she looks the part.
So when rumors began that she was being considered
for the role, she seemed like a shoo-in.
The studio's announcement at Comic-Con that
she'd been cast simply confirmed what fans
had already suspected.
Alden Ehrenreich as Han Solo
After Disney and Lucasfilm announced a Han
Solo standalone prequel to Star Wars, the
big question was who would play Young Han.
Over 3,000 actors came out for the part, but
the Hail, Caesar!
star was considered the front-runner for weeks
before the studio revealed that they'd landed
Alden Ehrenreich.
"This is the best kept secret in Hollywood.
The identity of this person is Alden Ehrenreich."
The only thing that's been surprising about
this news, really, is that he's nabbed not
just one feature film, but a potential trilogy.
Hey, you know what Han would say.
"I got him!"
"Great kid, now don't get cocky."
Benedict Cumberbatch as Dr. Strange
Sherlock as the Sorcerer Supreme was considered
a winning combination ever since Benedict
Cumberbatch was first rumored to be attached
to the Marvel Phase 3 pic.
Not only is he a fan favorite, he's also a
dead ringer for the character.
So, when Marvel finally confirmed him as their
choice for the adaptation, it made perfect
sense.
"This doesn't make any sense."
Adam Driver in Star Wars: The Force Awakens
When Girls star Adam Driver was first rumored
to be attached to Star Wars: The Force Awakens,
many expected him to play the bad guy.
After several red herring efforts to distract
from the possibility, LucasFilm finally confirmed
his casting, and he was indeed playing the
film's heavy, Kylo Ren.
In addition, as many also suspected, Ren is
the wayward son of Han Solo.
Seems like the force was strong with the rumor
mill this time.
(heavy breathing for Anakin Skywalker's lightsaber)
Matthew McConaughey in The Dark Tower
The Oscar-winner was rumored to be circling
Stephen King's apocalyptic western for months
before King himself confirmed that Matthew
McConaughey and Idris Elba would star as Randall
Flagg and gunslinger Roland Deschain respectively.
The only real surprise for King fans is how
non-mythical the character is in the long-anticipated
movie version, as opposed to the mirage-like
creature he was in the books.
Even so, the official announcement of McConaughey's
role was news to almost no one.
"To that I say amen.
To that I say alright, alright, alright."
Kurt Russell in Guardians of the Galaxy 2
Fans of Marvel's Guardians of the Galaxy got
to watch in real-time as Kurt Russell was
cast in the sequel as Star-Lord's father.
"You're half-Terran.
Your mother was of Earth.
Your father…
Well, he's something very ancient we've never
seen here before."
Once he was rumored to be eyeing the follow-up
film, reporters caught up to him only to learn
that, at that time, he hadn't even seen the
first movie!
Still, Marvel eventually confirmed Russell
will indeed star in the film after all … as
a sentient planet that somehow fathered a
regular-sized human.
Hey, if we can love a talking tree…
(I Want You Back by The Jackson 5 playing)
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know what
you think of these not-so-secret casting choices…